they were symptom free but now officials
say two people evacuated from China to
Germany on Saturday aren't fact infected
with the new corona virus they were
among a group of more than 120
passengers flown to Frankfurt on a
military plane from Wuhan that's the
Chinese city at the center of the
outbreak the evacuees are now in
quarantine in a medical facility they
will be there for two weeks the infected
are two German citizens they are being
treated in a hospital in Frankfurt where
doctors say they aren't doing well on
Sunday Germany's Health Minister
defended the decision to carry out that
evacuation Fukien fighting Hina must not
departure in China we had to and were
able to assume that symptom-free
compatriots were returning to us they
were still symptom free in Frankfurt and
in that sense they seemed healthy but
incubation time means in a situation
like this but what we've seen can change
relatively quickly that shows exactly
why the quarantine was right it's in
Thailand hoping on wish to try one of
those people who was on that plane joins
us now Yannick vice is a German student
who is living in China he's now in fact
under quarantine at an airbase in
southwestern Germany Yannick first of
all thank you for speaking with us I
wanted to ask you how's your health how
are you feeling I mean this has been
quite the ordeal for you and everybody
who was on that plane
[Music]
here from the of course this is a
difficult situation for all of us this
type of current team
I think nobody expected this when we go
to China and of course we were fine and
we are well treated and of course here's
quite a lot of medical support so if
something would happen we get an
immediate and an evacuation to a real
Hospital in Frankfurt what's that
quarantine like so you're currently at a
German military base what
the facilities like do you feel we're
well taken care of and and how are you
coping personally well right now we are
here at a military base
the building is separated from the other
buildings we have tents around oh so
there's no way that a known soldier or
somebody else can join us in our house
but also we are not allowed to leave to
later our house of course we are not to
go outside but we are not allowed to
pass the fence but the facility here is
very very good everybody of us has a
single room you we want to we want to
prevent an outbreak here also of course
in the facility so this kind of
isolation is I think the best
opportunity to manage this thing Yannick
tell me about the evacuation itself you
were one of around a hundred people
flown out of China at the time you were
not aware that a couple of people on the
plane were infected right but we are all
wearing masks during the evacuation in
the plane for all the time so I think
the risks that we infect us there is not
very high and but of course it's quite
possible and that's why we have here
this kind of quarantine because I think
it's necessary because nobody can say in
my healthy or not now you were studying
in Wuhan right what was life like in the
city once this outbreak happened what
what did you experience well of course I
was there for half a year and at the
beginning everything was starting for me
it's a living City eleven million people
are living there and suddenly all of
these 11 million people nobody's at the
streets anymore
we do have Giants routes which are
completely empty you have
and nobody is inside there are no cars
there are no something else most two
shops are completely closed and only
some supermarkets are open left there
there are enough groceries and
everything else that's right but for me
as a student I don't have the
opportunities to cook for myself very
much so yeah the last time I instant
noodles and vegetables and fruits of
course I'm no better food here now
Yannick I mean has those those numbers
start to increase the number of people
infected the death toll rose how did
that make you feel how scared were you
of course it's very settle is increasing
but to be honest I think there's there's
so many infected people and not so many
infected people if you compare it to
normal normal influenza I think yeah we
should be a little bit careful about
this but I think it's not that dramatic
Yannick vise he's a German student he
was recently evacuated from China from
Wuhan due to that a corona virus
outbreak you sound very calm thank you
so much for speaking with us we really
appreciate you taking the time this
patient's health took an unexpected turn
for the better the 70 year old Chinese
woman came down with the corona virus
which has already claimed hundreds of
lives but the virus vanished from her
body after doctors in Thailand
administered an unusual cure this is the
standard treatment that we've used with
patients it's a mixture of anti-hiv
drugs and a flu drug which china used to
cure MERS patients the mixture of both
treatments shows vast improvement 48
hours after applying the treatment and
the result turns negative
further tests will determine whether
this cocktail will put an end to the
corona virus epidemic China is
struggling to contain the disease the
army has flown almost 800 medical staff
and 60 tons of supplies to Wuhan the
city at the epicenter of the outbreak
after receiving the order we immediately
began to make arrangements for the
mission carefully selecting crews and
coming out with four different flight
plans considering the high risk of
infection we also took measures to
protect ourselves and provide a safe
cabin space more than 300 people have
died from the virus in China almost
15,000 infections have been registered
across the country in Wuhan and the
surrounding Hebei province hospitals are
being built in record time to absorb the
strain on the health sector outside
Hebei the government is desperate to
slow the viruses spread in the city of
nju every household is limited to one
shopping trip by person every two days
public transport is disinfected the next
week millions of Chinese will return to
work after an extended Lunar New Year
holiday to put such measures to the test
or for more now we go over to Matias
Burling our correspondent in Beijing
Matias the number of coronavirus cases
keeps rising in China more and more
people are dying is this going to
continue getting worse before it gets
better
that's what most people expect the
numbers are rising the numbers are
rising at a faster pace most of the
cases that we see the new cases that are
registered are still inside who by
province inside Wuhan mostly and the
cases outside of this area are rising at
a slower pace so that gives the hope
that the virus might be contained inside
this quarantine zone but this is far
from from sure because there is a long
incubation period and we might as well
see the numbers taking off in other
parts of China in the next few days I
understand a new purpose-built hospital
has just been finished in Wuhan how is
that expected to help in tackling the
corona virus outbreak the new hospital
has more than 1,000 beds they're badly
needed considering that several
thousands of people in the city have
been diagnosed with the virus and we
keep hearing reports about people being
not able to get their diagnosis because
test kits are lacking and other
admission problems in hospitals so these
beds are badly needed but the Wuhan
government has stopped stepped-up other
measures as well so for example they
have announced we don't know really what
they are really but they have announced
to have quarantine zones where people
who are who are sick but who are not
sick that they need to go into the
hospital where they have to stay and
will possibly be taken by the police
into these quarantine zones the military
has stepped in helping to distribute
food and other supplies to supermarkets
so we are seeing everything we hear from
Wuhan is pointing to a severe emergency
this health emergency Mateus is also
having a massive economic impact on
China how is that making itself felt
today is the day where according to
initial plans the holiday the New Year
holiday should have ended China is
pretty much in a lockdown economically
around this time of the year because of
the holidays but as you can see all
these shops have not opened today the
government has extended the holiday so
if until now the economically there was
some kind of a lucky coincidence that
this this crisis fell on to a holiday
season now we are going to feel the real
reasons when production when commercial
activity will not pick up after the
holiday but he is thank you very much
that was correspondent Mattias Berlin in
Beijing